how's it going everyone it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
mcu and today we're going to talk about
one of our favorite
subjects spider-man one thing that
everybody has been wondering lately and
a lot of rumors have been going around
about is
the title for the third spider-man film
in the marvel cinematic universe with
tom holland there's been
a lot of speculation about what it could
be but it appears that it could have
been
right in front of our face the entire
time and if this title ends up
being true then it certainly does tell
us at least a little bit about what the
plot is going to be for the third
spider-man film in the mcu
so i'll break down everything you need
to know in this video but first if
you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
mysterio funko pop just subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below to enter so first and foremost
full credit to charles murphy at
murphy's multiverse.com he is the one
who noticed this
he has pointed out that both esquire and
maxim both
very very big websites and magazines
for quite some time now have listed
spider-man 3
as spider-man homesick now again these
are pretty big magazines and websites so
perhaps they know something that we
don't know perhaps they have figured out
that the title is officially homesick
now if it isn't the title big websites
like this have gotten things wrong in
the past of course
but on the other hand many titles have
been leaked online
we all pretty much knew that avengers
in-game was going to be the title of
avengers 4
that is until the russo brothers pretty
much came out and said nope that's not
the title but that's because it was
leaked and they didn't want everybody to
know the true name
of course that was the name so we could
have a similar situation here where both
of these huge companies actually do know
the title
and it is homesick now to push it even
further charles murphy said that
although they cannot and won't get an
official confirmation
from the studio he did do a little bit
more digging and he said on his website
murphy's multiverse.com
as we reported the other day set
construction and
prep work for the film has already begun
in atlanta where it
is also being referred to as homesick so
it does seem like this
could be our title and if it is let's
talk about what that means
homesick of course it's sticking true to
the home in the title
but he's homesick meaning he's not at
home which makes a ton of sense
considering the fact
that when we left him in spider-man fire
from home he was framed for murder
mysterio framed him and he also exposed
his true identity so it's not like
spider-man can pose as peter parker
because now everybody knows that peter
parker is
spider-man so peter can't go back home
to aunt may he can't go to school he
can't go
to any of his friend's house because
they'll be monitoring his friends
all of the authorities are going to be
looking for him so he's not really going
to be able to go
anywhere where they would think he would
be now of course spider-man does have
some sort of help he does have happy and
he does have nick fury
two very important powerful and awesome
people to know in a situation like this
nick fury is a head of shield national
security world security
and happy with tony starks peter's
mentors right hand man
and he played a big part in spider-man
far from home and although you probably
won't be able to catch peter parker
anywhere near stark industries
happy could definitely help him in some
way or form and the same goes for nick
fury nick fury can hide him but they're
still going to have to clear his name
his identity being exposed was public
everybody in the world is going to know
that peter parker is spider-man and
pretty much everybody in the world is
going to think that he murdered mysterio
that's not something that you can just
clear up by making a call
so they're going to have to figure out a
way to clear his name but in the
meantime
nick fury can hide him or he can send
him to somebody else
many fans are hoping to see some type of
lawyer show up either matt murdock aka
daredevil or jennifer walters she-hulk
and not to mention peter has made a very
powerful friend
in new york now doctor strange and given
the title homesick it does seem like
peter is going to be going away and
staying with somebody else
so if this is the title let me know what
you think about this and let me know who
would you like to see
spider-man team up with in spider-man 3
homesick
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on
all the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you